my current role is in economics at the
hind school and I teach an energy in the
is really bringing energy and the
environment together and looking at it
through a sort of economics lens so that
students can understand things like what
are the ramifications of imposing a
price ceiling what are some things that
one wants to look at when thinking about
the regulatory process and so forth so
I'm currently working on two projects
one is looking at pollution and sort of
the evolution pollution in the US during
the mid 20th century when pollution was
very severe and looking at the mortality
impact the other thing that we're
working on and I'm working with a group
of co-authors is really looking at the
u.s. historical experience with respect
to climate change in both of those
projects the project related to climate
change and the project related to the
use of coal for home heating one of the
reasons why we want to understand the
American experience is because that
itself is inherently interesting but
also because both the severe pollution
from the use of coal for home heating is
occurring in the developing world today
and similarly we expect many developing
countries to experience big increases in
temperature related to climate change
and so understanding how was that the US
was able to sort of moderate the
relationship between high heat and
mortality that is you know mitigated
will we hope be helpful in terms of
thinking about policies that will be
effective in the developing world I
think that our work is primarily of
interest both sort of to the general
population who's interested in
understanding the sort of evolution of
energy in the environment in the u.s.
context so just from a background
perspective but also some of the things
that are happening our might be relevant
for developing countries and that's I
think where government policy makers are
also interested people potentially at
the World Bank or at the IMF because
again I think understanding the effects
of climate change what we did here that
allowed us to mitigate it
in the u.s. context and what might be
useful avenues for mitigating it in
developing country context
you